[Music]
she's the face of change for
court and for country amy coney barrett
is the presidential pick
who would bring an ideological shift
onto the bench of the u.s supreme court
today it is my honor to nominate one of
our nation's most brilliant
and gifted legal minds to the supreme
court
i have no illusions that the road ahead
of me will be easy
either for the short term or the long
haul
i never imagined that i would find
myself in this position
but now that i am i assure you that i
will meet the challenge
with both humility and courage the
president waited until the day after
ruth bader ginsburg lay in state in the
u.s capitol
but no longer this fast track nomination
is designed to place a new justice on
the bench before the election
there were questions over amy coney
barrett's background in politics before
there are once again dogma and law
are two different things and
i think whatever a religion is it has
its own dogma
the law is totally different
she's a devout catholic conservative and
pro-life
her politics would further tilt the
balance on the supreme court six
conservative justices
to three liberal and that has big
implications
for big decisions the u.s supreme court
is the ultimate legal arbiter in this
country on abortion
on immigration on gun control on
everything
including perhaps november's election
donald trump's opponents criticize the
nomination
and its timing the american people
should make no
mistake about it a vote for judge
barrett is a vote to take away health
care
and its protections for over a hundred
and thirty million americans
then of course there's the election and
donald trump's claims are without
evidence
over postal vote fraud this scam
that the democrats are pulling it's a
scam the scam will be before the united
states supreme court
for a newly conservative leaning court
calling this election
would be the split decision to split the
country even more
james matthews sky news washington